how's it going bros welcome back to day
king light the most ironic title ever
can what fat brats you needed stop
barging into my check man what is this
oh thank geez what did that do I didn't
really do anything did it okay so this
lit up and then I can I'm so sorry don't
kill me
just don't kill me uh-oh we're actually
fine is there anybody in there don't ask
silly questions you are gonna get me
salad made by myself us bros help me out
a little bit here friend Freddy bros
that sounded weird alright let's just
keep going here and collect all the blue
pin in battle alright pause if you want
and then we go oh [ __ ] hell I'm so
jumpy we're in this game I don't even
know why ah I wash your screen I'm sorry
i shouldn't've the neck
oh there's so why don't you tell me hey
hey guy that was easier ha alright we
are back and the black and let's see
because of what I just [ __ ] said okay
uh-huh
interesting alright let's keep going hey
how's the smella well what about me
buddy how do you feel I feel how do you
think guys whatever okay I'm gonna jump
this so okay sigh deep breath we're
gonna do this together
okay Oh God Oh oh [ __ ] we're so [ __ ]
sorry I'm sorry man woman whatever
Raymond huh you just had to ride that on
the other page that paperweight wasting
quiet okay so we're in a new this is a
new mace
I didn't real impress what are you stop
you gotta arrive then at least give me
some help
what is that the snake no it's a hole
yeah you know what I'm think I'll take
the awkward part
call me Craig cray but I ain't going
down day-day unless there's a cookie
down here sign or some [ __ ] that's my
rolls that's what I said but I but I I
guess we don't really have a choice do
we
I just had to put a hole in the darkness
and I have to go down can't yet we're
sick oh god what is that what is what Oh
Oh a creepy tunnel I can't wait to see
what's gonna happen in here clothes sex
guy is starting to piss me off okay at
least we have glow sticks now at least
we can party you know what I'm saying
you know you know what I'm saying she
knows
right okay we have flares great they
were so helpful the other time
as a clue there's how you can go this
way oh I really really really don't like
this place
this is really bad is it a like we've
been in some bad places man but this
just takes the price and there's no
award it's no good at whould you pants
that Cineworld worn but I don't even
want to wear it Oh God
all right let's go where the creepy
noise came from because that makes sense
hello tree branches don't touch me don't
touch me okay you're touching me Jesus
Christ
have some respect oh god what's that
what's that red little dotty I think
that's a remnant what don't come force
me oh okay
hello good moustache fashionista star
okay
what
what am I supposed to do bottom I'm just
a little Sarah of course it's all God it
was thought that's y'all I love that
hella better make it stop I would be
okay I don't even know what scorning
means how can I school in so money if I
don't know how to score
we have scones is that what she meant
oh god no it's not the scones they're
here what was that was this College
Sarah we don't have any whipped cream we
don't have any [ __ ] wait the crane
baby and yeah don't eat my crackers you
cracker day you run stim okay all right
let's take the map
uh-huh this way huh great body loads my
phone and upload I don't [ __ ] know
and I don't want to [ __ ] know Oh
I that was okay I have pliers I have
play I don't even have any remnants I do
actually I'm a liar I will filthy
goddamn liar
uh-huh I know it's a dead end but it
like doesn't not man I don't know and
really oh god this remnant is running
out at it
oh that this is definitely a hidden
doubt why is it it's it's stripping more
than before
yeah sure she said haha sorry okay uh
that was really annoying I apologize
it got farted I think he's like me he
farts when he's nervous
Oh God you can see the phone like Snoopy
Shafi a little bit why do I keep walking
in the same areas no bueno
man oh boy oh man okay it looks like we
can oh yeah we've been here [ __ ]
impossible yes it hopefully this is not
a dead end
why is that let's take it easy
Oh God it really is like a real horror
experience having a farting plug in your
lab this is walk slow and not run
because I think they find you when you
run that's it's my little theory I don't
really want to test the opposite so here
we go all right good job
I see the pipes and they scare me like I
don't even I don't I can't I ran out of
em it well if it was me we would never
run out of glow sticks that's his home
things
what is great what she touch with you
you don't warn me Oh God oh okay well we
found they said that the place to be I
thought I told you never before you [ __ ]
with me Hannah
why she's here okay well I saw them to
map something there's another part like
this one okay don't worry brush I chose
we're together forever and ever and
we're gonna die so [ __ ] hard yes this
is going there you are my little love my
remnant yes I was like a fire yeah all
right
hopefully no one is touching my ass
while I read this all right
all right all right very good
very very good let's walk in here again
this the tension man the tension it is
not under control
and hopefully oh my use flares to keep
you safe but what if I do
oh I don't want I think we manage to not
know can you not I had a bad day already
Jesus Christ was all right the plan is
to not die a horrible death
I found the sigil they said it will be
fun they said go in the sewers they said
it will smell like [ __ ] they said well
can't be worse than Edgar that's all I
say god damn it we done [ __ ] up then
we hmm please leave flares
there's no flares a goddamn note you
just had to leave a goddamn note in a
medicine cabinet you little prick I will
find you I will find you
all of you I'm sorry ball father you
know oh great
that is fantastic
I'm alive es una miracle osa alright
that's a man one day if you can't fight
scream like a little [ __ ]
good night today they say no wonder
those days
this is Judgment Day woods
what prevail get his pants he would get
this [ __ ] together and he will get this
tape together there really no ok please
for the love of pills and bros I got
flares all right I'll take it
I got a flare baby oh and we can go
north here just oh my god that's hopes
and dreams and oh what is this what is
the flag no fire I English [ __ ]
paradis found you yes yeah but I don't
know what it got crow man more like bro
man I don't think so I really don't
think so
but hey let's be optimistic here maybe
it ain't so bad if rains ain't so bad
maybe ok we don't even know where it it
it's there my god it's my lucky day
we're taking one step at a time
oh god oh god she's behind me she's so
[ __ ] behind me don't touch my ass
don't turn back I'm not turning on she's
so [ __ ] there
okay okay let's just get the [ __ ] back
alright don't hold the flag it's not
available didn't Oh God I'm what I got a
sigil is this oh where is it forward
forward forward forward forward forward
forward forward forward she's so [ __ ]
happy that's right come on baby I'm
sweating like a Sarah hora pay [ __ ]
this way you don't need him to know that
but okay this forward don't look back
okay oh god oh god oh god I got I got I
got it what do you think Sarah oh please
what does that a man may why does that
mean oh oh hell no all right dear this
pres hope you enjoyed in the ethanol
episode we did pretty good today my
throat hurts which indicates we did [ __ ]
they were like when you're watching I'll
see you the next one looks like there's
gonna be more syringe it let me brother
say awesome
ah yeah that's a really bad man